my mom's like incredible she's very very
brave I hope she knows what she's
praying for you the bravest thing that
my mother ever did was go to law school
at 44 years old after being out of the
workforce for 20-some odd years and
being a stay-at-home mom for just as
long she was an aspiring journalist and
she ended up getting married and having
kids young and then raised her kids she
woke up one morning as she proclaims and
just felt like all of a sudden she had
no responsibilities her children were
grown and so she took the LSAT passing
and going to law school and passing the
bar and is now a full-time lawyer
it's just taught me that the sky is the
limit and it's never too late if you
want to make a change in your life my
mom's like incredible
my dad died when I was younger and my
mom just like stepped up it's hard to
raise kids as a single parent I have a
disability I have Tourette syndrome and
it's harder when you're raising a kid
with Tourette's I'm a comic and my
mother like ghost head-to-head with me
she's also the funniest person I've ever
met my mom is a total Queen is she's a
judge just having that role model to
look up to throughout my life was really
awesome I would stop by her courtroom
one case my mom addresses a defendant
and she pulls her glasses down to the
tip of her nose if you think that
speaking to someone in that manner is
appropriate you will end up right back
in this courtroom and I will make sure
it is in front of me and like very queen
my mom had my brother when she was 18
and had me at 21 so she was fairly young
we grew up on the border between Tijuana
and San Diego living undocumented my mom
had been only in the US for maybe four
or five years had been going to English
classes and she came into my second
grade classroom
and surprised me by participating in one
of the monthly readings for their child
I was super excited to see my mom there
her voice was shaking she had a very
thick accent I remember like
disregarding all of that and being full
of joy that my mom was joining me in the
classroom I don't think I ever thanked
my mom enough for that moment for all
that vulnerability for braving through
what might have been maybe an
embarrassing moment there is a specific
moment that stands out for me but it was
when I was in third grade my dad and he
got promoted that entailed us having to
move it was in the world for me oh my
god to leave my friends my girls album
had just came out so it was a huge
transition for my mom at the time she
was working as a financial aid counselor
at Fayetteville State University I knew
how much she loved that job us moving to
this new city also means that you're
having to really just change our whole
life for leaving my family
we're leaving friends it's during that
time of her trying to figure out what am
I going to do applying for a job after
job after job I remember some moments
where it seemed like mom seems upset but
I remember her just staying strong with
her face and always being very hopeful
there you know applying for a lot of
positions and going through applications
are going through interviews she
eventually got a position working at the
school that I attended she just in that
moment taught me a lot about not ever
doubting yourself I don't think she
knows how brave she is she who yeah I
will because I'm I'm one of seven and
geez sorry whew my dad passed away in
2006 the fact that she's carried on with
the amount of strength and care
and unconditional love and support for
each of us is huge so I hope she knows
that she's very brave she's very very
brave personally I'm professionally you
can do it something that's gonna make
you happy to pursue it I know people
that run into her in court and say she's
really damn good at her job putting me
above herself and making sure that I
felt included in that parent family
tradition that was happening in the
classroom the way that she can go from
work and would come home and cook dinner
for us show up to all of my volleyball
games I don't think that I always
appreciated it but mom I love you so
much thank you for being a total queen
and a role model for me as long as you
just trust trust the situation and trust
yourself and hold on to your faith you
can power through really anything I love
you mom happy Mother's Day
felice di Leela's mother's damn all of
me happy Mother's Day mom I love you and
I know that you hate the beard but I
will shave it off and just for you